-Welcome, welcome, welcome t
"The Tonight Show."
Thank you for being here.
You made it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
President Biden
is still on his European tour.
And this weekend,
he and the First Lady met with
Queen Elizabeth
at Windsor Castle.
Here they are.
Yeah.
This is what the James Bon
poster is gonna look like
by the time
they release that movie.
Yeah, they look like
they're waiting to
buy wands at Harry Potter World.
You can tell everyone felt
a little awkward,
'cause that's not a photo,
that's a video.
After his meeting with
the queen,
Biden talked to reporters
about what she was like.
Watch this.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
I'm pretty sure that will be
Biden's last meeting
with the Queen, don't you think?
I don't care who you are.
No one wants to hear that
they remind you of your mother
Something tells me
Biden would not do well
on Tinder, right?
"You remind me of my mother.
Alright, we'll just leave
right here."
-"From the look of you."
-Yeah.
"Well, just from
the look of you.
Your overall scent."
-Yeah. "Your odor."
-"Yeah, just --
I'll get the check.
You go home."
Yeah, well,
this is Queen Elizabeth's
13th meeting with
a sitting U.S. president.
That is amazing.
And even more amazing
is that she's kept a diary
of all those meetings.
-Really?
-Here are some excerpts. Yeah.
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
What?
She -- [ Laughs ]
-Wow!
-There's also an audio book.
An audio book.
I didn't know that.
And you saw her writing it
That's amazing.
-Yeah, it's amazing.
Well, after meeting
with the queen
and all of the leaders at th
G7 conference in the U.K.,
Biden traveled
to Brussels to join
even more heads of state
for the NATO summit.
Everyone wanted
something from Biden.
Germany asked him
to stand up to Russia,
U.K. told him
to keep an eye on China,
and France wants him to rene
"Emily in Paris"
for a third season.
-Oh.
-They love it.
Yep, Biden attended
the NATO summit in Brussels,
and it was pretty
interesting to see him
interact with
other world leaders.
Here, listen to
what he had to say.
We got some audio.
[ Laughter and applause ]
What?
What is he talking about?
-"Growing up, Jack"?
-I don't know what he said
but that wasn't all he said.
-Really?
-He said more.
Yeah, later, he said this.
Just interesting the way he --
But, finally,
he left them with this.
We have one more clip.
There you go.
Just very interesting.
That --
[ Applause ]
Some more news.
Ahead of his meeting with Biden,
Vladimir Putin
was interviewed by NBC News,
and he was asked to recall
a story the president like
to tell about the time they met.
Watch this.
-President Biden says,
one time when you met,
you were inches away
from each other,
and he said to you,
"I'm looking in your eyes,
and I can't see a soul."
-But I do not remember
this particular part
of our conversations, to b
honest with you.
He probably has a good memory.
-Even weirder,
Biden also told Putin,
"You remind me of my mother.
Isn't that weird?
He can't stop saying it.
Well, here's some good news.
New airport screening technology
was just approved
that will allow travelers to
leave their shoes on
while going through
TSA checkpoints.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Finally.
Now the only person
taking off their shoes
will be the gross guy sittin
next to you on the plane.
But just to
keep things difficult,
they're gonna also make --
they're gonna make
you remove your socks.
I saw that...
-"Hold it. Keep your shoes on.
-Only Mr. Bean
will be the person
allowed to board the flight.
I saw that Wheaties
is commemorating
its 100-year anniversary
with a series of
limited-edition cereal boxes
I love Wheaties, yeah.
Well, this is cool.
Some of the boxes
are even paying tribute
to the everyday athlete.
-Oh.
-Check out some of these.
There's the "Co-worker
who won't stop talking about
how many steps
they took so far."
"I only did 13,433 today.
Yesterday --"
Okay, we're good.
There's also a
"Middle-aged man in Lycra.
-Oh.
Can't ride a bike without it
-I've seen those guys.
They call them MAMILs --
Middle-Aged Men In Lycra.
-Really? I didn't know that.
MAMILs.
-Yeah. They get all dressed up
like they're in
the Tour de France.
They go to Starbucks
to meet their buddies.
-Yeah. With the clanky shoes
-Yeah.
Up next, we have "Guy whos
giant vat of protein powde
has moved with him to
four different apartments.
Oh, there it is.
Powder can't go bad, right
And, of course, there is..
"Questlove throwing a baseball."
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Whatever.
-Some more business news.
Prada just launched
Prada Outdoor,
which includes a $995 volleyball
and a $650 Frisbee.
Take a look at this.
It's the first time anyone's
ever started a meeting like,
"So, you guys know how Frisbee
are just impossible to carry
They're, like,
impossible, right?
So what do you do?"
[ Laughter ]
Finally, everybody,
NBC is currently filming
a new game show called
"Ultimate Slip 'N Slide"
that will premiere right after
the closing ceremony
for the Summer Olympics.
Let's see how that's going
-Production has been shut down
on the new NBC show called
"The Ultimate Slip 'N Slide.
The show had to be
shut down after
an outbreak of
explosive diarrhea.
-Oh! Whoa!
-What?!
-I'll just say it.
Forget the Olympics.
Put that on TV
for two weeks straight.
I would watch every --
I'd watch it every --
Yep, NBC isn't happy
that word got out,
but they can't be surprise
that it leaked.
♪♪♪♪
New York just reached Presiden
Biden's 70% vaccination goal
And today most
COVID restrictions
in the state were lifted!
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Good job, New York.
That's right.
Restaurants no longer have t
space tables six feet apar
or use physical partitions
New Yorkers heard,
then were like, "Really?
'Cause we kind of liked that."
[ Laughter ]
"Can we put those back?"
The good news is the partition
will be gone.
The bad news is
they're going back
to where they came from --
the urinals.
[ Laughter ]
Now look --
I never knew
they were see-through.
I didn't know
-No. It's the number-one reason.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, you're right.
And if you're wondering
whether it's safe to eat
on the subway again,
the answer is,
it was never safe
to eat on the subway.
[ Laughter ]
Well, this is exciting.
Next month, New York City is
throwing a ticker tape parad
to honor the pandemic's
front-line workers.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right, a parade
for doctors and nurses.
It'll be like Mardi Gras excep
when you flash them, they yell
"Hey, get that mole
checked out."
You go, "Okay."
[ Laughter ]
"I appreciate it."
And this is nice.
In the spirit of being
environmentally friendly,
all the ticker tape
will be made from used masks
[ Laughter ]
[ Audience groans ]
That's right. The parade i
a great way to show the worl
that New York City
doctors, nurses,
and front-line workers
are the best.
And New York City traffic
is the worst.
[ Laughter ]
Some more pandemic news --
according to a new study,
COVID infections are droppin
where people are vaccinate
and rising where they are not.
[ Laughter ]
You can read more
about the study
in the prestigious medical
journal "Thanks, Genius."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah.
Well, this is interesting.
The world's first edible
and functional face mask,
which is made of melon bread
has been released in Japan
Take a look.
[ Laughter ]
The best part is, people can
hardly tell you're wearing one
[ Laughter ]
Can I see that one more time
We can't see it, but if she'
wearing blue shorts,
it's one of the best SpongeBob
impressions I've ever seen
[ Laughter ]
Let's get to
some political news.
Well, guys, President Biden is
preparing for his big meetin
tomorrow with Vladimir Putin
-Ooh!
-That's right.
After the G7, NATO,
and the Queen, it's like Biden
got through all the levels and
now has to face the final boss
[ Laughter ]
It's a pretty big
change of pace.
First, Biden was with the Quee
and having tea.
Soon, he'll be with Putin,
avoiding all liquids.
[ Laughter ]
I wouldn't touch anything.
[ Applause ]
No, I'm just --
Actually, no. Biden is
actually amped for the meeting
Today he pounded a half gallon
of Ensure
and crushed the carton
on his forehead.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, everyone's helping Biden
prepare for the meeting,
even some former Trump
officials, actually.
Yeah, immediately after Bide
opened his briefing book,
the Trump official was like,
"You're already one step
ahead of Donald.
So this is amazing."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"You opened it? Wow."
[ Applause ]
That's right. Advisers tol
Biden to be blunt with Putin
Then Biden delivered
a 45-minute monologue
on why that shouldn't
be a problem.
[ Laughter ]
Some TV news --
Last night was episode two o
"The Bachelorette."
And things got pretty intense.
We love that show.
The emotions on that can be
little hard to handle sometimes.
So we thought we could help.
Here's a clip of the episode
re-voiced with
the least emotional person
we know, Siri.
[ Laughter ]
This is "Let's Get Siri-ous.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Let's get Siri-ous.
-I didn't know the specifics
100%.
Alright, listen. That's
the bleeping stupidest bleep
Look, I get what you're saying
That was the dumbest thing
you could have possibly done
Alright.
She's out there upset, crying.
Look, man. I'm not putting
anybody on blast.
You already have.
I didn't put anyone on blast
Stop being like this, bro.
Be logical.
You're a grown-ass man.
Grow up.
-Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Well, guys, the Olympics
are almost here.
At last night's U.S. trials,
Ryan Murphy advanced
to the finals of
the 100-meter backstroke.
Afterwards, he shared his ke
to success. Watch this.
-A nice swim earlier,
but this one even faster.
What do you attribute that to?
-I shaved my chest
between prelims and semis.
So maybe that was
a nice little boost.
-I almost hate to ask.
How do you build on
this performance
as you head to the final?
-Well, I'm going to shave
my back tomorrow.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's pretty good.
If he wins the gold medal,
it's gonna be split --
half American, half Brazilian.
-Ooh.
[ Laughter ]
-And finally,
I heard about a family
that's dealing with a pretty
unusual problem. Check this out.
-A Buffalo, New York, family has
mysteriously received abou
100 Amazon deliveries sinc
the beginning of the month
but they don't know
who ordered them.
Boxes are piling up
outside the family's house
The same item is
in all of the boxes --
silicone brackets for
the inside of face masks.
They've received
more than 100,000 brackets
[ Laughter ]
-The family was like, "Well,
I guess it could be worse.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Earlier today, President Biden
and Russian President
Vladimir Putin
finally met for their big summit
in Geneva, Switzerland.
Yep. It was pretty much
the opposite of
the "Friends" reunion.
Yeah, Biden and Putin
met at this Swiss estate.
Yeah.
-Ooh!
-You may recognize it as
the haunted asylum
in every horror movie.
Actually, Putin found
the place on his favorite
house-rental site, AirKGB.
-Oh.
-Well, Biden and Putin
both arrived
within 20 minutes of each other.
Here they are
shaking hands outside.
[ Indistinct shouting,
camera shutters clicking ]
-Once the presidents
stepped inside,
they sat down
for another photo op.
Take a look at this. Yeah.
Looked like two dads waiting for
their daughters to finish
trying on prom dresses.
They're like, "That looks great,
honey, yeah."
Putin looks like
he's trying to remember
which one of those books
opens up the trapdoor.
He's like, "Okay, this one..."
"Say hello to the sharks,
Mr. Biden.
There are some piranhas
that were -- Hold on."
Then Biden and Putin
got down to business,
where it was just them,
a red table,
and Jada Pinkett Smith.
And that's what
I'm talking about.
That's when it gets --
That's when they mean --
Let's get down to business
Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The meeting was
expected to be five hours
but lasted only half that time
Not a great sign
when your summit
is barely longer than
"Peter Rabbit 2."
But after the meeting, the two
leaders agreed to keep in touch.
When Biden said,
"I'll give you my e-mail,"
Putin said, "I already have your
e-mail and password.
And Venmo.
Don't worry about it."
And this is nice.
The White House
said Biden gave Putin
a pair of
custom Aviator sunglasses.
Yeah. Putin says he's excite
to wear the Aviators
back home in Russia, where the
sun's out twice a year.
Biden also gave Putin a
crystal sculpture of a bison
Yeah. A crystal bison.
Weirdly enough, Crystal Biso
is also one of Trump's
old girlfriends.
-Really?
-Yeah. She's...
Oh, yeah.
-He paid her off -- $130,000
-130 grand, yeah.
-Yeah.
After the meeting,
Putin held a press conferenc
and was asked if he thinks
the U.S. and Russia
will now have
a better relationship.
And listen to his response
-What?
-Wow!
-What?!
-That's actually an
excerpt from Putin's new book,
"Chicken Soup
for the Russian Soul."
-Oh.
-"There's no happiness in life."
-Yeah.
It sounds like the slogan
for Russian Applebee's.
Switching gears,
according to an annual lis
that was just released,
New Jersey is America's
best state to live in.
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah! Come on! Yes!
[ Crowd booing, cheering ]
Yay! Yeah!
-[ Laughs ]
-Yeah! Come on!
-Wow!
Yeah, the key factors
they considered were
cost of living,
quality of education,
and access to gabagool.
-Oh!
♪♪♪♪
-Finally, speaking of
the Garden State,
yesterday,
at a New Jersey water park
a water slide
actually caught on fire.
Take a look at this thing.
Holy!
-Oh!
-There it is --
the best state to live in,
ladies and gentlemen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
A water slide...
Meanwhile, there was still
a 16-year-old lifeguard
at the top of the slide saying
"You can go.
You can go.
[ Drumbeat ]
[ Laughs ] You can go.
You can go. You can go.
You can go. Yeah.
You can go.
That's right -- the thing
just burst into flames,
which is why the slide's new
name is Gender Reveal Party.
Happy --
-Love you, Jimmy!
-I love you.
Happy Thri-day!
-Thri-day, I love it.
-Yeah.
-[ As Rebecca Black ]
♪♪ Thri-day ♪♪
-I didn't make that up, right?
Is that a thing?
-It is now.
-Happy Thri-day?
-It's Thursday.
-Yeah, but I'm -- Thri-day
[ Laughter ]
'Cause the energy --
I'm already
in the weekend already.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, guys,
this Sunday is Father's Day.
That's right. So --
[ Cheers and applause ]
So make sure you call your dad
even though
you'd both prefer a text.
[ Laughter ]
But talking with Dad
on Father's Day is fun.
It's a great way to catch up
on which neighbors
are annoying him
for which reasons.
[ Laughter ]
"This guy parks his car in front
of his house all the time.
[ Laughter ]
This guy, he plays his music --"
"Okay, good, Dad."
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
Father's Day is this Sunday,
and Americans are expected
to spend over $20 billion.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
That story, again --
on Sunday, over 20 billion
scratch-off tickets
will be sold.
[ Laughter ]
"Good luck, Dad."
Let's get to some news.
After his week-long trip
to Europe, President Biden
is finally back
in Washington, D.C.
When he saw his schedule fille
with meetings on infrastructure,
immigration, and inflation
his first thought was,
"I already miss Putin."
[ Laughter ]
Yep, returning home
was pretty emotional for Biden
mostly 'cause
on the flight there,
he realized that he
"Home Aloned" Pete Buttigieg
[ Laughter ]
"Pete!"
"Keep the change,
you filthy animal!"
[ Laughter ]
But this is big.
Today, Biden signed
the Juneteenth National
Independence Day Act...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...making Juneteenth
a federal holiday!
[ Applause ]
The bill hit Biden's desk afte
it was passed in Congress,
but 14 members of the Hous
voted against it.
[ Audience booing ]
Can we --
Can we see who they were?
Yeah.
-Oh.
-That's -- That's about right.
That's about right.
[ Laughter ]
That looks like the white-pain
sample section at Home Depot
[ Laughter and applause ]
"What do you think, honey?
Should we paint the bathroom
Mike Rogers or Thomas Massie?"
[ Laughter ]
And I saw this -- Jared Kushne
just signed a book deal.
Yep, his book will come ou
next year.
But he already
has a few titles in mind.
Check these out.
First --
-Ah, here we go.
-What's up, dude?
-Let me guess.
Well, you're gonna make fu
of Jared Kushner, right?
By saying a bunch
of fake book titles.
-I mean...yeah,
that was the plan.
-And, of course, each titl
will pop up as a graphic,
so everyone can see it
and "laugh" about it.
[ Laughter ]
-Right.
That's kind of what I do.
It's the whole first
10 minutes of the show.
-I -- I know exactly
how this will go down.
Okay, the top of the scree
will have, like, a weird picture
of Kushner, and it'll say,
"Kushner's Book Titles."
And then, under that,
you'll list fake titles, like,
"50 Shades of White."
[ Laughter ]
Or -- Or
"Diary of a Wimpy Adult."
[ Laughter ]
Or "Are You There, Don?
It's Me, Your Creepy
Son-in-Law."
[ Laughter ]
And then you'll do,
"Eat, Pray, Ask Daddy
for a Million Dollars."
[ Laughter ]
Oh, or -- or "Gone With th
Slightest Gust of Wind."
[ Laughter ]
And then you'll finish it of
with something like,
"The Sun Also Rises (While I
Sleep Standing Up in a Coffin)."
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
I'm guessing
that's how this is gonna go.
-Yeah.
You nailed it.
-Well, that's a fun bit.
You should do it.
[ Laughter ]
-All right.
We'll do it tomorrow.
Perfect.
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys, get this.
I read that for next year'
Super Bowl, a 30-second ad spo
will cost a record $6 million.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
And apparently, some companies
are already testing out
shorter ads to avoid high costs.
I mean, just --
just check this out,
this new ad I saw from Old Navy.
Look at this.
-As you know, we here
at Old Navy sell clothes.
[ Laughter ]
-I just --
-Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Check out this ad
I saw from Home Depot.
-Plywood, lamps, shovels,
things of that nature.
[ Laughter ]
-"Things of that nature"?
-Wow!
-These are rough.
Here's the last one here,
from Olive Garden.
-Breadsticks.
When you're here --
[ Laughter ]
-"Breadsticks when you're here."
-Gets to the point.
-Breadsticks when you're here.
-Yeah.
Some business news.
I heard that rental-car prices
are at a record high
and could even double by August.
-Ooh.
-Yeah.
For car renters on a "Budget
hoping to save a "Dollar"
to see the "Alamo,"
this news is --
this news really "Hertz."
[ Laughter ]
Goodbye, everyone,
and see you all at the Emmys
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-Wow!
Wow!
-Well, guys, with COVID
restrictions lifting
all over the world,
a lot of countries
are opening back up
to tourists this summer.
In fact, many of them have
released updated travel poster
to help entice visitors.
Take a look at these.
This first one is for France
It says, "We're still gonn
stand 6 feet away,
but it's just because
we don't like you."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wow!
-Again --
This next one's
for the United Kingdom.
It says, "The pubs are open,
and the sun is shining.
Okay, the second one's a lie."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Here's one for Fiji.
It says, "Not just a Zoom
background anymore."
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
-This next one is for Estonia.
It says, "Come figure out
whatever our deal is."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Finally, this last poster'
for Spain.
It says,
"The sooner you come back,
the sooner you can brag
to your friends
that you went to 'Bar-thelona.'"
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, I went to Bar--
Oh, we had so much fun.
-Where'd you go?
-What's that?
-Oh, we just went to --
We just went to Bar-thelona.
-Oh, really?
-It was just so --
It was so fun.
-How long were you there?
-We -- We were there two days.
In Bar-thelona?
-Yeah.
-We were -- Well, one day.
It was a layover.
-Not a week?
-It was a couple hours.
-Yeah.
-But, yeah.
I had so much fun.
I felt like --
I'm just, like, some part of m
was from Bar-thelona.
-Really?
[ Laughter ]
-Guys, listen to this.
A computer programmer
in the Philippines
gave his newborn son
the name
Hypertext Mark-up Language
Or HTML, yeah.
[ Audience groans ]
Yeah, I'm pretty sure the baby's
first word will be, "Why?"
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a new study out
of the U.K. found that
the aging process
is unstoppable.
[ Laughter ]
When they heard that,
a bunch of people in L.A. said
"We beg to differ."